let's backtrack to what you just said
about the campus stuff because I know
this is a place where you get a lot of
heat for this when you've talked about
the rape yes I went to Oberlin College
and everyone gets triggered and thirty
people and a dog fled to a safe space
they had a safe room there was a therapy
dog apparently and xxx triggered young
women and they went to a safe room and
they were so we only try to plate parse
that out what I mean what does that
actually mean because I know I know we
know what it means and yeah what we joke
about this stuff oh I wish I didn't know
but they literally because you were
coming baby yeah and I would give them
PTSD now I have been lecturing on
campuses for years and it used to be
they come and argue and sometimes we
part as friends or go to a bar and you
know kind of have a good time like human
beings yeah and if someone presents me
with some good data and good arguments
I'll change my mind I've changed my mind
many times as I look forward to doing it
again
yeah but they are we're not just
something has changed in the last few
years on the campus and there's been
this medicalization of of the of the
curriculum and they need trigger
warnings for their classes and trigger
warnings for this and that and as I said
they needed them for me and they needed
a safe space where they could retreat
because as one of them put it someone
would be invalidating my experience it's
like the worst thing that can happen to
you right so it wasn't like a good thing
to happen and then because you can't
just go by your experience you have to
test it and and see if your
interpretation holds up to criticism
they were not interested in any kind of
criticism right so when when you hear
this happen on you and you see this
happen to you and you say okay here's
the empirical evidence about what's
happening with rape on campus and then
they say what is their counter argument
is the counter-argument that there's
more rape that goes underreported for X
Y or Z or they're not counting you know
girls that got drugged or something I
mean what's the I get that we've become
this society that's afraid of every bit
of information but what's the counter oh
yeah well they cite their own studies
but I've spent in many years and so many
other people looking at these
methodological failures and that if you
there are ways in which I could we could
throw together a survey tonight and and
ask people questions and find an
epidemic of whatever you want all you
have to do is ask questions that are a
little vague and it helps to to ask a
non representative sample of people and
that's what they do they ask they
usually a mix of serious questions but
then a few vague ones that's all you
need now does it mean your study is
going to be valid no does it mean you're
going to generate some useful propaganda
for your cause
yes yeah all right so I saw that that
piece at a toe Berlin and then the other
thing that I saw you got heat for was
the cat calling right there was this
video about cat calling and you've sort
of said we're written about that this is
not really a thing not really thing that
it will it exists but not a thing to be
upset by so well it's complicated and as
I said there are times where it's very
threatening but you have to make
distinctions and this is the basis of
thought I mean human rationality making
distinctions and being out in the public
square there are going to be
interactions you know people will come
up with petitions people beg for money
people will say things it's just part of
being alive yeah and these control
freaks think that we can police
everything that's said on the street and
they were actually suggesting that it be
against the law to cat call a woman
well again I make a distinction between
something saying hi beautiful I mean
frankly that wouldn't bother me it
mighta bother me and I was younger but
as you get older you don't mind right uh
but when I wish somebody saying
something disgusting or frightening that
is that's talking you that's very
different but they to them it's all the
same it's all a micro or macro
aggression and they want to law against
it and and what I pointed out my video
is that in Washington DC there's a place
where you can walk and you will be
catcalled and I have walked there many
times and it's in a very busy park near
Dupont Circle and it's a lot of women
dressed for success you know and their
Manolo Blahniks they're walking through
and the men
catcall well the men are homeless
you know people living in this park and
they make comments so there is a huge
class difference between these women are
we supposed to think these women need to
be protected from these guys who are the
have-nots right so that's an interesting
discrepancy that it's not Wall Street
bankers walking down the street making
these comments where then there's sort
of an added layer of financial
difference and social status and all
that it's usually coming from people
beneath I support always not a lesson oh
it is like a bad enough to dismiss it
you know I get what you're saying
there's a wild discrepancy between you
know I you're cute or whistling at a
girl or versus leering and following I
think men should know that it bothers
women I'm not sure it bothers all women
I mean I think it depends on the woman
and you know it's very complicated yeah
I don't want the women who were the most
hypersensitive and sort of freaked out
about male attention I don't think they
should be able to write the rules
I think they should consult other women
what I suspect you would find is that it
can be annoying I mean as I said I
remember being younger and being annoyed
but it was mainly any well there were I
mean didn't happen that much on Wall
Street or in Manhattan but so there did
seem to be an element of class involved
but but I think you have to you know I
think in different cultures the women
react to it differently there are
different mores and things but in my
neighborhood in Washington DC I don't
see it happening and you know where I
live so basically what I sense is you're
pretty much saying that your fear in
this would be that if you were to allow
some laws to be passed related to all
this stuff that you're handing the power
over sort of the authoritarian oh you
had it police they can arrest anybody
yeah and it would be these I mean I
think in DC it would be these poor guys
and so I I think in you know most men
want to be decent human beings and they
should know women don't appreciate it
and that most don't and especially if
it's
in you know kind of pushy and certainly
if it's offensive but but then you're
not don't make laws and don't invite the
police in this is there's so much of
this in inviting authorities in and some
have called it the pink police state
you know this feminist police state that
we have on campus where you are kids and
public universities the young men are
afraid to tell a joke or to say anything
that I know comedians of comedy clubs
that are afraid well they better they're
unwelcome on campus it's a hostile
environment for humor yeah and so that's
why you have to be careful in sometimes
you'll get what you wish for but then
you get a lot more you get a lot more
repression authoritarianism it's just
not worth it yeah so is some of that
also that the feminism movement has been
a victim of its own success in a weird
way because it seems to me that
feminists now should be fighting so much
more for women's rights in other
countries now of course we have a long
way to go here but when we see all kinds
of horrible things happen you know women
still can't drive in Saudi Arabia one of
our biggest allies in the Gulf you know
this is not an enemy country and all
over the Middle East and all over Africa
where women's rights are basically
trampled on if not non-existent
why don't feminist groups focus on that
at all it you have you do have genuine
patriarchal oppressive societies and and
what's happening to women's rights in
Iran is terrifying of course in Saudi
Arabia in many parts of the world I've
been to international women's
conferences and you meet these women who
represent women from their countries
I've met them from Cambodia and Yemen
and Egypt and so forth and it's it's
very inspiring it's like meeting the
Elizabeth Cady Stanton and Susan D
Anthony the the feminist for mothers of
their society yeah and you would think
that the you know on the campus these
young women would be especially young
women that are idealistic and want to be
activists you'd think they'd be making
common cause with those women yeah
instead these women at Oberlin and
Georgetown and you they're protesting
the men on their campus because they and
they feel they are they feel that they
are like these women that are oppressed
in Iran that they have it as bad or
worse so it's a it's delusional yes so I
think there's something much bigger
going
here and I think this is why so much of
our audience especially on Twitter likes
what we're both doing and what people
like Joe Rogan and God said and then my
life many others are talking about
there's some weird movement of
authoritarians where the left now which
is supposed to be about free thinking
and debating ideas and doing this right
where the left is now throwing out half
the people I had Sarah hater on last
week and this is an ex-muslim who stands
up for every liberal ideal the the left
should love her and they shun her at
best they you actually treat her worse
than than being shunned when I wrote my
first book which was protesting the
authoritarianism of feminism and the
anti intellectualism the conspiracy
theories all that I expected to have a
good reception from feminist scholars
because I just assumed there was a
silent minority of a silent majority of
reasonable women and I did I heard from
some great women and from Nate nadine
strossen president of the then president
of the ACLU
I heard from Erica Jong you know this
pro-sex feminist novelist and so and
they were great but my colleagues in the
Academy were furious that I had
criticized and they thought that
criticism was the same as a kind of
betrayal and show that you were on the
side that side of you know the forces of
evil so didn't just disagree with you
they thought you were evil yeah they
don't just disagree with you they think
you're evil and that you give them PTSD
yes so you give them PTSD and then it
also doesn't give them a license to say
and virtually do anything they want to
you because I could give you a zillion
examples of times where I've seen anyone
that shifts a little bit away from
people on the Left where they are
slandered and smeared and wrecking
horribles hating is it because they do
to other people exactly what they say
the right is doing they demonize they
objectify they other eyes to use their
word they micro/macro they're they're up
there they're massive macro and micro
and nano aggressions they don't hesitate
to be rude snarky and there's so much
meanness I don't understand feminism
with meanness it was well I mean I know
there was some eccentric angry women
from the beginning of
second way but mostly the lived
experience of most women who were
enjoying their liberation was happiness
and joy and and being friends with men
not going to war with them yeah so where
does this strange collusion of all these
people that all end up on the left doing
this you know I've said repeatedly on
this show the reason I talk about this
all the time and the reason I tweet
about their aggressive left and want to
talk about this is because I don't want
the left to go over the deep end and
that's why I'm talking about a
cross-section talking with a
cross-section of people from literally
all over the world because I'm afraid
what happened to the right where it went
so far right is happening the left right
now what brings these people together do
you think when it when often they
shouldn't have a lot in common well I I
will tell you what I know best is among
the feminists is a small group in the
universities gain control of the
knowledge base I mean what we think we
know about men and women so you're a
journalist and you need to know
something about the wage gap or you need
to know something about women and in in
in education you go to these people and
they are what the journalist doesn't
know or the politician or the interested
party doesn't know is that they're
spinning and they have an ideology that
drives their research so I think a lot
of people don't realize that there's
it's that there's so much spurious
scholarship so they take it seriously
and now it's there are untruths
exaggerations fickt euch factoids that
have been repeated so often they're
almost beyond the reach of rational
analysis and and if you question them
you are by definition a sexist or worse
so they got a certain amount of power
just through this this this information
this scholarship about how in this case
about how oppressed women were yeah so
you have to sympathize and then they
they then kind of went off the deep end
with this psychobabble and these
psychodramas about I'm triggered and you
know it I mean at Brown University they
a year or so ago and there was a story
about it you may have seen I'm sure you
did in the New York Times but Judith
Shue Lovitz
at Brown University they had a debate so
it was a feminist to feminists actually
a libertarian feminist and someone else
another feminist debating rape
statistics and you would think that's
perfect what more could to students want
they can hear both sides and their sides
well represent no they didn't want the
debate at all and they formed a safe
room and in that safe room they were
playing tapes of frolicking puppy dogs
they had bubbles coloring books play-doh
yeah maybe I made up the play-doh oh I
think they had pleasure yeah so this is
so infantilizing and again i and many
other feminists of maya generally look I
didn't think this is infantilization
this isn't this is the opposite of what
feminism should be and when I got to
college we threw out the dorm counselors
and the the guardians of our virtue and
all that we wanted to be in charge so
what went wrong do you think if there
was a was there a moment that it
actually that's something snapped if in
fact something went wrong and the
feminist movement went from these two
extremes what do you think happened
there well I think I know what happened
no one listens to me I wrote this
article in The Daily Beast where I
pinpointed what happened these we shall
call this these fainting couch feminists
and purveyors of myth they've been
around for a long time they've been in
Gender Studies is too bad but in 2011 a
little-known apparatchik
no other no a government official yes
Santa I was gonna sound conspiratorial
yeah if you don't know but in this case
it's true she sent out a letter to all
the colleges and universities her name
she was the assistant secretary of civil
rights
Russell and Holly and she sent out to
all the colleges and I think her
intention was that they take more
seriously that women are harassed on
campus and there was too much sexual
assault but she went overboard she's
terrified the universities and made it
seem like if they didn't immediately put
alt like most men on trial and get him
out of those schools and believe women
because she claimed there was this
epidemic in this epidemic of sexual
predation in the
men at campuses like Yale and swathmore
and so we're just preying on women so
she sent this letter and the schools now
can be sued under title 9 this Edmond
equity statute it's a wonderful statute
it was meant to be there to give women
equal opportunities in education but
it's been twisted now and it they've
kind of declared martial law on men
campus because of this letter was 2011
you look at that date and then you see
it brought words like trigger warning
and safe space this whole mindset of
rather somewhat paranoid young women and
their mentors on campus it gave them the
power to to make a federal case
literally of their perceptions yeah
that's so interesting cuz I can see the
line now to when you were talking about
the cat calling why the slippery slope
exists if you were to create a law well
then you could be in this similar well
now once you have a law they already had
title nine officers but since 2011
that's probably the area of greatest
growth on many campuses they have dozens
and dozens of people monitoring how the
boys are treating the girls at at
Wesleyan and these are mostly very
privileged kids yeah and there's a lot
of drinking and I'm sure drunken hookups
but they have redefined drunken hookups
to to be rape of the a young man against
the elements I call that then there's a
rape epidemic if you're going to enlarge
the meaning of this horrible orbit
you're going to enlarge it to include
drunken hookups right so I see so
there's so many pieces here that that
are related to feminism and so much of
this authoritarian stuff and the college
stuff
the Yale thing which we were both
tweeting about that happen we don't have
to go or so with the professor that
wrote the piece about you know the the
Cosmo Queen Costello in costumes and if
you see someone that's wearing something
offensive either ignore it or use your
free speech to engage them and why you
two aren't happy with it and hopefully
have a conversation about it then that
professors husband I believe is the Dean
there he got into this argument with the
student and the student basically said
and it was all caught on camera
basically said this is not a place
of intellectualism this should be a home
I really like it takes a lot to really
get me crazy but I thought this is
dangerous now what's happening you know
and I also I usually don't feel like a
grandpa but I felt like a grandpa like
you kids like how stupid are you kids
but it really struck me as now we have
something systemic that we have to do is
dangerous and here's why
some leftists I've seen are they're
embarrassed by it who wouldn't be but
they say oh it's just kids acting out no
it's not just kids acting out these are
kids who have been fed a lot of bad
crazy information in their ethnic
studies or gender studies where it's
highly politicized scholarship they've
had and they may if they went to elite
high schools they probably had it since
you know 10th grade they've been reading
these conspiracy theories about how bad
the united state of a Western culture
and particularly the men it's
patriarchal male hegemony so forth and
they believe it and and they do not have
much knowledge of history so if they are
doing things that to people that know
history remind you of the McCarthy era
or even the Salem witch trials
listen just in terms of hysteria and
contagions of hysteria they're not aware
of it I mean and what this is a nut this
doesn't happen often but there was one
young woman that and this is all over
not all over but you can find it on the
Internet she burned my book she this
gleeful young woman took the organs boys
and burned it and I just I just as a
teacher and a mother I just thought
burning a book have a good history you
know right and now I assume then she
tweeted it at you and put ahead well it
was on it was on tumblr and someone who
sent it to me yeah all right so
basically they're they're creating an
atmosphere where almost everything I
mean it really feels 1984 Orwellian
reverse everything is this sort of
doublespeak and reverse of how we're
supposed to have debate right I mean if
you can't have an intellectual debate in
college well how are you going to get
out to the real world to do it right and
the Supreme Court has ruled many times
that freedom of speech is most important
on the college campus it has refused to
do sanctioned speech codes and the
courts have refused to do this but
schools have them anyway and it our
universities become places where you
have to be piper protective of students
protect them from ideas and your your
goal is to achieve massive amount of
comfort and safety
you have undermined the purpose of your
being yes if you exist at the
universities don't exist for that
purpose going back to the time of the
Socrates the Academy was about debate
and and counter-argument and yeah and
being able to reason and uh uh yeah well
I think that's why people are responding
to us right because we're trying to
bring that back what else do you think
we can do because you know I see this
stuff and I talk about it all the time
but every now and again I got I mean 100
honestly I do feel a little guilty it's
rare but I do once in a while like you
know in something like the what happened
at University of Missouri I empathize
with these kids if they feel you know if
there were racist things happening it's
not the whole thing sounds a little
unclear as to what exactly was going on
the poop swastika and somebody said that
word and all this but I have no doubt
that there was racism on the campus and
there's racism in Missouri and in the
country I've met doubt so sometimes I do
feel a little maybe guilty isn't the
right word but a little no I understand
exactly what you're saying it's take it
then and I have never really gone on
about the race issues the way I do with
the gender issues I think they're very
different there's a particular history a
very specific history with
african-americans in the United States
and and and I don't like to see the
women's movement pretending that their
women are been oppressed in the same way
that is just not true depends on which
women and if you were an upper middle
class white woman you've had a very
different history yeah and this was
supposedly the great insight of
intersectional intersectionality but
they didn't seem to apply it very
consistently and certain groups like you
know most men seem to be written out of
it so it's just not it's not a
consistent body of work they need
to bring in more critics they need to to
hear from dissidents and if they think
well ours is a compassionate movement
and they are they're going after
people's jobs and as I said there are
these these sort of Twitter mobs that
want to destroy people's reputation what
did you make of that professor at
Missouri the woman who was standing
there screaming at the reporter who you
know she was saying we need some muscle
around here to get the reporter out this
be thug
it was thuggish and many of the little
scenes I've seen on the campuses a
reminiscent of like these struggle set
sessions they had in the Cultural
Revolution in China and those were run
by students I mean it people say well
you wouldn't compare them those people
you know we're throwing people out of
windows I agree that I don't they're not
comparable in that way for one thing
these kids on our campus don't have that
kind of power thank God but some that I
see such they seem so intoxicated with
hatred and self-righteousness I don't
know what they would do if they had
power real power they have power to hurt
people and you know their jobs and
reputations then that's already awful
look I mean it's awful what's happened
to so many young men and I have no
apologies for criminals if there are
criminals on campus and taking
advantages of girls that's awful but
what is more often the case with so many
that we've read about it's young men
that that you know it's like a year
later the girl takes a young woman takes
a women's studies class and rethinks
this bad hookup and then he's brought up
on charges
sometimes not even told what the
specifics of the charge are yeah we've
had too many of those and so that's what
worries me is these people get carried
away and these gender studies and other
things and then they they have no regard
or maybe no knowledge of the First
Amendment of due process of the the
history of the the battle that was
fought for freedom of speech now of
course it will be turned on them so
you're already seeing now feminists are
getting in trouble I think there was a
professor that was hired it was fired
for using the f-word yeah well now you
can see that I mean it's happening right
now it's turning on them right now you
can see the left eating it
self right and as someone on the left I
probably shouldn't be taking that much
joy in it but because it's been so
warped I actually am I want you know as
we've been calling them the regressives
I want them to I want them to go the way
of the dinosaur not for this enough of
this I know and we bring back it's just
a environment of openness and with jokes
yeah there shall be jokes
you